surface roseanne barr she kind of seems
like an unlikely conservative superhero
doesn't she but there she was last night
reviving her eponymous TV show that went
off the air 20 years ago now she's
playing her old character this time is a
true-blue Trumpster dealing with liberal
family members I know so many families
you know that are divided over the
election still and they still like you
know our fightin and stuff so we wanted
to show that and how our family deals
with it and we all have the hope that
people will start talking to each other
again because that's what we need
did you see joy Behar's face she wasn't
buying that at all well when the
original sitcom Roseanne debuted think
about this
Reagan was finishing his last year in
office and then nine seasons later Bill
Clinton was in the middle of his second
term in office oh my goodness how things
have changed for America in the interim
but I have to tell you it didn't
surprise me one bit I think we predicted
it last Wednesday on the angle when the
ratings came in today showing Roseanne
had absolutely crushed it nabbing 18
million viewers for the debut it's
awesome now for years the entertainment
industry has moved ever further to the
left pumping out films and television
series that often offend or they just
simply don't resonate with millions of
Americans with a slightly more
traditional sensibility and as producers
push the envelope on political issues
and sexual depictions even during the
so-called family hours of television
well they may have curried some favor
with the viewers on the coast but I'm
telling you they lost many others and
the people they lost they needed a
reason to return to broadcast television
and last night Roseanne gave it to them
you know I've long wondered why the
decision makers in Hollywood hadn't seen
the writing on the wall sooner how is it
good business to deliver content that
right off the bat
half of the country is going to be
repelled by remember 14 years ago Mel
Gibson's Passion of the Christ it
premiered and ultimately racked up over
600 million dollars in total domestic
and foreign box-office evangelicals and
Catholics flocked to the film over the
Easter weekend many seeing it more than
one time it was an absolute tour de
force so one would have thought that the
industry would have seen that success
and tried to replicate it but they
didn't really do that it was almost as
if the entertainment executives forced
themselves to look the other way in
right off conservative success in their
world as some kind of strange anomaly
but Roseanne Barr took the audience
seriously and she was willing to reflect
who they are fairly even their politics
I think the voice of working people as
absent from television and I think we
always had that and we have it again and
there's nothing on television like it
reminds me a lot of when we first
started there was nothing on television
like our show and it's still that way
she's a true innovator and Roseanne
shows us that Trump voters they're not
monsters they're not deplorable and no
they're not stupid they're real people
with real dreams who get into family
fights and they grapple with health
crises and money troubles and remember
the show the middle that's also at ABC
that's been a big hit it's another
middle-class family and they go to
church and they love each other no
matter their dysfunction and who can
forget oh my gosh I loved Everybody
Loves Raymond that was pretty
conservative show that ran for nine
hilarious seasons and then of course
remember Tim Allen starred in that well
rated Last Man Standing which was
curiously canceled last summer despite
the fact that it outperformed on Friday
nights it too skewed conservative but
let's face it for too long many of you
felt increasingly isolated from the
popular culture because the popular
culture seems to have nothing but
ridicule and disdain for you so not
surprisingly there was a pent-up
yearning for exactly the type of show
that Roseanne Barr produced real
families real problems and real
intra-family political divides that can
provide real laughter so will the huge
success of Roseanne mean we can expect
to see similar efforts at other networks
I wouldn't hold your breath
over the years I've had the chance to
meet some of the folks whose job it is
to greenlight these series and they
actually admit that they have alienated
a wide swath of the American public but
they don't really seem to care they seem
more worried about what their friends
and their colleagues will think of them
maybe at cocktail parties dinner parties
if they backed a conservative theme show
so despite all the talk of diversity and
inclusion giving each other ribbons and
awards Hollywood remains still one of
the most intolerant industries in the
world an insular as well you tried going
on an audition being known as openly
conservative good luck the Liberal Dogma
is extremely difficult to crack and the
powers that be make exceptions once in a
while but it's usually for only those
stars with huge name ID people like you
know Jon Voight or so that's just a loan
or Rosanna herself but in the meantime
millions of TV viewers are voting with
their eyeballs and they're looking
forward to seeing where MS bar takes
this working-class narrative maybe right
up to 2020 and that's the angle